you spent the summer doing a play yes
with someone who's been here many times
a terrific actor as well Jesse Eisenberg
and you guys were doing this play in
England yes at the West End we did this
play called the spoils the spoils was it
a great experience it was a wonderful
experience Jesse's a great guy you know
he doesn't go out much but when we did
go out we had a lot of fun and we're
very busy doing the play and he's a
wonderful guy a wonderful actor you
wouldn't think the two of us would would
get along I don't know why but well
Jesse's very he seems like he'd be very
kind of fastidious and proper like I
know someone every time he comes to us
the show that would is too big for my
intellect okay what would you say he's a
little stiff he's very nice particular
and any you know any is kind of shy he's
shy right here's what he does every time
he's been on the show afterwards this is
not pressure for you to do the same
thing you don't have to but he writes me
a beautiful little handwritten note in
nice little handwriting and sent it to
me and thanked me for having him on the
show I've done the plate twice with this
guy I've known him for two years he's
one of my best friends in the whole
world
I have never gotten a handwritten note
from him ever Jesse if you're watching I
see how it is man yeah I see how it is
so what's he like when he goes out on
the town uh-oh Jay well you know Jesse
doesn't drink much and when he does
decide to he drinks a hot toddy is this
favorite drink what yeah you guys know
what a hot toddy is yeah yeah do you
know what a hot body is uh so I thought
I sorry I'm sorry I said that no no I'm
not sorry you said it because now I do
know
yeah you know I hot Tottie I think it's
like it's like it's like it's like tea
but whiskey and it's heated up and then
he'll sip on it and after two sips he's
like I'm really feeling it right now I
think I should go I should go yeah and
so it's really fun what are you what do
you drink what's your drink
hi I'm a martini kind of guy i I used to
like drinking beer but it makes me gassy
okay no I stopped drinking it okay you
have no teeth and you're gassy but I got
a hot buddy yes you do that's I really
wish the tooth is missing in the front
you know I've got a hot body
[Laughter]
you